three in the middle of a few as well so
a Johannesburg skyline like this one is
a sight Anthony filbrick rarely sees
from his clients homes the owner wants
to convert her pool into a pond so you
would actually have rock underwater
keeping the swimming pool water clean
involves a lot of work and it harms the
environment we still keep the existing
systems I really would like to convert
my pool into a natural wetland area
because I'm using way too much chemicals
every day the water quality is not great
if it's not nice on the skin when you
get out of the pool animals don't like
the heavily chlorinated water either
Philbrook transforms pools like this one
into a natural wildlife habitat the
architect was inspired by the swimming
ponds popular in Austria in the 1980s he
took the idea to South Africa
Johannesburg has such good weather that
one in three houses has a swimming pool
so if you look at an aerial photograph
the whole city is littered with them
there are a hundred thousand of them the
whole city these conventional swimming
pools are ecological deserts they are
full of toxins and really quite
unpleasant
this pool is set to become an oasis
badly needed by the local wildlife water
is scarce here the South African winters
are especially dry sometimes fire
warnings have to be issued the animals
are struggling to survive they can't
find water anywhere plants play a key
role in rene chirring the pools anthony
Philbrick has been working with this
nursery for years he's always on the
lookout for new native species the
architect wants to use and preserve
South Africa's rich biodiversity when he
began realizing his vision back in 2007
there were only 15 water plant species
available to him thanks to his demand
the selection has more than doubled
the growers are all or all people who
are mad about plants so you tell them go
and find some more plants to grow for
ourself they go out and they come up
with all of these wonderful and wild
species for us it's been fantastic
that's how the architect found this
particular plant the water starlet's
blossoms glow like stars in the night
sky against the green background these
plants are fairly rare they're from the
macro land they're really beautiful and
their environment is slowly shrinking
the Western Cape as we know the is
getting less and less rain and these are
these are swamp plants from an area
which is fast drying up endangered
species find a safe haven in the wetland
pools that improves their chance of
survival these plants are destined for
the pond of a longtime customer he's
created a watery paradise and natural
landscape in his own backyard ideal for
swimming and home to local wildlife it
used to be a dried-out lawn the swimming
ponds bring nature back to life and they
create new jobs
this water landscape function is like a
natural pure vacation facility a wetland
is created alongside the actual swimming
pool it contains plants that clean the
rainwater from here the water is pumped
into the pool
in order to clean this the only way we
could do it is have this biological
filter as I see it that's it
the plots as they grow they taken
nutrients out the water as long as
that's happening you don't have algae
growth a couple of kilometers away
Natalia d-nut also had her swimming pool
reconstructed it used to be a normal
rectangular basin the new natural pool
has brought about many changes the pool
really did bring us closer to nature
it's brought a lot of consciousness to
not only my family but my friends as
well because everybody's interested in
what kind of pool this is and how is it
so clean water from the pool tastes
better than tap water the owner likes it
and so do all the animals